um with uh with like in the element days
like I mean I gotta believe
there was just partying going on like
like you're 16 years old you cut off
your dreads like you you know like you
you're no longer but in contact with
your dad and like it's like the preacher
kids finally are starting to party like
did you did you kind of like
you know like when your relationship
with your dad
cut off did you find yourself like now
I'm you know like just let loose and
yeah it took me it took me about like a
year or two because I was
around that time I was very uh I was
still very like socially awkward because
I never was allowed to like really have
friends growing up and I kicked with my
brothers but even them I hadn't seen in
a while so just like being in like a
public setting and like starting to like
kick it with my friends and like go to
like Little House Parties as a teenager
and stuff it took me a while to like be
a normal person it's like be able to
like conversate do people think you're
like a dick and you're just like no I'm
just socially awkward yeah I was just
quiet you know just quiet shy but as
soon as I started to break out of that
like a year or two later and then I did
have I got drunk for my first time when
I was 16 after I won Street League
Kansas City 2011 and we were at the
after party it was in a club I don't
even know who I mean who let me in there
or whatever but
um like Sheckler and like everyone was
like giving me drinks and they were just
peer pressuring me to drink and then I
blacked out bro I was so drunk and I was
like so so I was so
unknowledgeable on what alcohol even did
to you in the freaking everything yeah
because my dad or my mom never drank I
wasn't a part of like a lifestyle
growing up so I like knew about it a
little bit but like being that drunk and
then like waking up the next day and
feeling the way I did I was so confused
I was like why the [ __ ] do I feel like
this wow I feel like
I feel like I heard at some point
like
that you were like just capable of
getting super hammered and then just
waking up the next day like totally
hungover and just winning first place in
like the biggest contest yeah I did do
that a few times
I don't know how bro I don't know how I
still trip out on that to this day like
I was around when I was like 17 18 and
at this point like I was you know I
wasn't like drinking all the time but
you know me and the I moved out on my
own when I was 17. me and the boys moved
into this house in Huntington nice house
like a gated community and we do parties
all the time so I would probably drink
like you know once or twice a week and
and it goes around that same time when I
was like 17 we we actually rented this
other house in Newport for the weekend
to like throw parties at but it was we
did it the same week in a Street League
and we weren't supposed to throw on the
first night we were supposed to wait
till after the contest and then of
course we end up throwing one the first
night I probably only slept like up
super hammered me and all the homies we
used to like drink so much and then I
woke up got like two hours of sleep and
then somehow went to the contest and
skated skated great
and won the thing and then part of it
even harder that night yeah I remember
like like whoever it was was telling me
about this they're like man we've seen
with like
it like night is just a different Beast
man you know like just did it like it's
like Babe Ruth like not sleeping the
night before and just like crushing the
home run record for that Stadium or
something like that yeah for sure I mean
sometimes maybe it could help with like
the nerves and contests and kind of like
loosening you up a bit and making you a
little more like Carefree because I mean
with skating content skating and
competition is just hard it's a weird
mixture of like feelings out there like
it's so easy to get nervous it's so easy
for your legs to just like feel like
they're not working like they normally
do because you're [ __ ] overthinking
every single thing when it's really like
dude we do these tricks every day like
you shouldn't be like stressing on it
that hard but as soon as you get into a
contest you just think differently are
you listening to the music during the
contest yeah yeah I got airpods in
listening to music that actually helps
me out a lot yeah helps does everybody
do that a lot of people maybe like half
the people I feel like it's a new thing
like in the 90s and 2000 where people
listening to the Walkman during
competition you know it's like oh yes
I feel like that would help you out a
lot it definitely helps but at the same
time like my music is it has to be up
really loud to to get through all the
sound that's going on around you like in
like the arena and it is
harder to like hear your board and stuff
so that could mess with people a little
bit but for me it just helps keep me
like more focused and just like not
worrying about what's going on around me
and just more in the zone what who what
are you listening to in the in the
earphones and then are you superstitious
like if you have a good run with like a
certain song or band like do you want to
play that the next time or does it just
kind of on play or no I don't know I'll
normally have like a playlist or
actually I I use SoundCloud a lot when I
skate because I listen to a lot of house
music and like EDM like I don't know if
you guys know about that music but
um some of it is more like heavier like
hyped up like techno and stuff but for a
contest I would actually rather listen
to like more mellow house music like
like black coffee is one of the artists
he like is more like African style house
music and it's just more mellow and
really like puts you in a good Zone
um and on Soundcloud they have all these
long mixes that are like an hour two
hours long so you don't even have to
worry about like switching the song a
bunch you're just like one basically
just one song the whole time and it just
has changes but you're just dialed in
yeah yeah [ __ ] I feel like I I would
like to listen to music if I played
professional sports yeah you always play
better yeah I don't know why basketball
players don't do it or it's it's weird
to hear you say that you can get nervous
in a contest when like you're just I
like the the Street League contest maybe
they're just like more frequent like
Street like you're not tripping right
it's not that I'm tripping it's just
like it's just because I care yeah I
always think about this because at this
point I've been
I've been skating Street League for 12
years now
I've won a lot of them and I feel like
at this point in my career I shouldn't
be going to a contest and stressing on
winning
especially keeping in mind that like
skateboarding is a [ __ ] very young
sport like yeah a lot of people a lot of
my fans still expect me to go out there
and win just because I've won so much in
the past but if you look at skate
contests and who is normally winning
they're on average like 21 years old
like the guy Gustavo Ribeiro he just won
the super Crown he's like 21. you know
when yuto came out on the scene like he
was winning contests when he was like 18
19 20 like those are his like
easy years of winning contests and
you're 27 now 27 about to be 28. same
thing with me my easiest years of
winning contest was actually
from like
16 to like 20.
those are the easiest years why because
your body's in better shape just because
I don't know I think I think I feel like
skateboarding just goes through these
like generations of skaters who are
really good at contests and they come on
super strong when they're young and then
they just get like better and better and
there's just like another person every
like few years it's weird and it like
never fails there's always someone new
crazy but what makes the next person
better is that he has new tricks that
nobody's ever seen or he's just Landing
every everything he tries or like what
yeah I mean consistency and yeah just
like technical tricks I mean that's
really what it comes down to nowadays
and something that I actually dislike
about contests nowadays
because
it's just so technical you know like I'm
I've always been pushing for bigger
rails and contests I want there to be a
[ __ ] 20 rail out there so you can go
you know back flip the thing and get a
high score or like flip into it and
you're gonna win the [ __ ] contest
because you're sending you're putting
your [ __ ] life on the line but
instead they keep making these like nine
ten stair rails and then and then you
you got it you got to be doing like
[ __ ] triple nose grinds and like them
flipping out and like flipping flip out
flipping spin out and just all this
crazy [ __ ] and I'm just like grass it's
no secret that Johnny Knoxville and I
are a little older too old to deliver
the mail but we can still lick the stamp
and I think we look pretty good right
here this remain
s were signed for selling
everybody grab these Johnny O
skateboards while you can I'd suggest
you hurry